legendary musician Chuck Berry dead at  90 the music pioneer who was often  referred to as the father of  rock-and-roll has died according to the  st. Charles Police Department the  singer-songwriter was reportedly found  dead Saturday at a residence just  outside of st. Louis Missouri and they  confirmed the sad news on their Facebook  page writing the st. Charles County  Police Department  sadly confirms the death of Charles  Edward Anderson berry senior better  known as legendary musician Chuck Berry  [Music]  Barry wrote iconic songs such as Johnny  be good Maybelline and roll over  Beethoven and was one of many  entertainers who performed on Soul Train  in the 70s  [Music]